Bonjour, je suis Jean Daniel Youtube, le créateur de youtube
Ici , des millions de vidéos sont postées chaque mois.
N'utilisez pas adblock !
Vos cachets monsieur.
Merci.
Je vous l'avais offerte...
Je suis très fier de mon entreprise. Je tiens à vous faire visiter.
Youtube, c'est d'abord l'échange entre le créateur et les internautes, à travers les commentaires.
Quel espace d'échange formidable !
Lisez moi un commentaire.
"Cette vidéo c'est de la merde j'ai perdu deux minutes de ma vie."
... un autre commentaire
"Venez voir ma chaîne je fais des vidéos sur Minecraft !"
- Un autre ...
- "Il fait ça que pour l'argent..."
Lisez moi un commentaire sans méchanceté ni promo !
"Cool la vidéo !"
Formidable ! Mettez un pouce vert !
D'ailleurs moi aussi je fais des vidéos sur YouTube...
Nous adorons nos créateurs ! D'ailleurs, sur la page d'accueil de notre site
nous mettons en avant de nombreux nouveaux youtubeurs qui méritent d'être connus
car ils proposent du contenu riche et varié.
On met qui aujourd'hui en page d'accueil ?
Squeezie.
- Demain ?
- Squeezie.
- Après demain ?
- Ensuite ?
- Squeezie.
- Suite à cela ?
- Pour changer ?
- Squeezie.
Jamais entendu parler de ce...Squeezie...
Moi non plus.
Comme le dit souvent Sandrine...
Vanessa.
...Nous adorons nos créateurs.
Bonjour je suis Anthony de Carglass...
Oula non ! ...Mais...
Il faut attendre cinq secondes.
Ah oui c'est vrai.
... le résultat est presque invisible et votre pare-brise retrouvé sa solidité...
Nous sommes à la pointe de la technologie !
Une de mes fiertés ? Les sous-titres automatiques.
- Vous lisez quoi là ?
- Catpulte
Bienvenue chez nous, vous êtes embauchée !
Je suis pas peu fier de mon truc !
Monsieur Youtube ? J'ai un problème !
J'ai envie de faire des vidéos sur YouTube sauf que j'ai pas d'idées et absolument aucun talent.
Mais ça, ce n'est pas un problème !
Bien au contraire !
Merci monsieur YouTube !
Beaucoup de potentiel !
Nous avons des vidéos pour tous les goûts. Vous aimez les jeux vidéos ?
Yo tout le monde c'est PGM Gamix et aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur un simulateur de chirurgie !
Regardez comme il s'amuse !
Oui, par contre monsieur son écran est éteint.
Comment ça ?...
...je prends le scalpel, alors déjà, ah d'accord le jeu m'agresse directement il y a plein de sang qui est en train de s'écouler...
...je suis un malade ! Je suis un malade on va essayer de le récupérer av-av-avec le marteau-teau qui-qui- ah excellent !
Revenez, on se casse !
Nos youtubeuses beauté ont BEAUCOUP de talent !
...autour du lisseur ! On attend quelques secondes...
... Oh mon Dieu ! Oh mon Dieu je brûle !
AH AU SECOURS JE BRÛLE ! JE BRÛLE VIVANTE !
- J'ai un extincteur si vous voulez !
- Non laissez le feu faire son travail...
- Bonjour je suis Anthony de Carglass.
Un seul impact sur votre pare-brise et à la moindre secousse, c'est la catastrophe.
Avec notre résine spéciale que nous injectons en moins de trente minutes, le résultat est presque invisible et votre pare-brise retrouve sa solidité. Et le plus souvent...
- Fallait faire attention.
- Oui mais non c'est moi...
Faut faire gaffe, il y a beaucoup de portes dans cette entreprise !
Les vidéos de cuisine, on adore !
Et maintenant il ne vous reste plus qu'à enfourner à 300 degrés celsius pendant 3 heures.
Attendez ,c'est pas la fille de tout à l'heure ça ?
Monsieur Youtube, J'ai un problème !
J'ai utilisé une musique de Rihanna plus de trois secondes dans ma vidéo et elle a été supprimée !
Est-ce que vous avez une solution ?
- Trois secondes tu dis ?
- Oui je crois que c'est ça...
Un... deux... trois !
PLUS JAMAIS T'UTILISES UNE MUSIQUE DONT T'AS PAS LES DROITS !
Au revoir...
Notre nouveauté ? Désormais nous n'attendons plus que vous fassiez le buzz, nous le créons nous-même !
- Désolé monsieur, le chat il veut pas buzzer.
- Ah...
Ben jetez-le !
Forcément.
Va me chercher le bébé s'il-te-plait.
- Vous voyez ? Youtube est un espace formidable où se rassemblent des créateurs unis par la passion
Oups.
Venez sur YouTube !
Casse toi !